Hello各位同學大家晚安
看得到我嗎?
等一下我把這個薩克斯風的吹嘴
這個我清理一下
我一邊看一下大家的留言
我先給這位問國具的同學
我剛好有看到國具
我們就直接從這個國具開始講
我清一下麥克風
我剛剛在吹
等一下
上面有同学问国具
来给这位国具的同学
你在讲的这个左侧交易跟右侧交易
我不确定你的定义跟我的定义是不是一样
我不确定
所以我把这个清完
不然里面都是口水
我把它清完
跟你好好地讲
ok
好來吧
先從你的問題開始
你說今天日K收在693塊下緣
週K是長下引線算有壓力
日K要向下翻亞當嗎
給這位同學
你對於要不要翻亞當的條件
看來不是很明確
我先问一下你应该有把我们这个频道新手必看的那个专区整个看完过对吧
里面包含亚当包含Jack帮我们录的那个翻亚当的练习那些你都有看吗
我需要知道这件事情
那我们不会去翻
不会我们不会去翻这种连续跌的这个最后面这边还继续往下翻
不会你说老爷这不是有跌破低点吗
对但是这个几率其实真的很低
你心中有一个底
如果这边是持续的这样子往下
他真的这么强
他根本连今天连撑住
就是这几根这几个小时
连撑住都不应该撑住
应该是这样子讲
好不好反而现在这个地方是前面
来这边有没有一个
一个很明确的整理区域
反而是这边翻下来包含最上面
的什么区域
它容易进入了什么区
来你自己对照一下这个地方
是这边到这边的什么满足区所以我完全不会在这边考虑任何空头的人家从1200跌到600你600才要空吗?不对
所以其实你有看到对的东西就是你有看到那个下影线
对吧
那周K是下影线在这边
压力
哪里有压力
这里我看到是支撑
支撑啊
边界在这里
有这个下影线在这里
我看到的是
是打击框在这个地方
只要这边成立
那后面就不错
这样啦
对吧
所以我不觉得
你需要去管左侧交易或右侧交易
一般在市场上面
我们讲的
左侧交易是什么
是指价格一路下跌的时候
在低点还没有产生以前
就一直接刀
接刀然后再下跌
接刀又下跌
这个叫左侧交易
那右侧交易的概念是
是行情已经转回来了
他才买在转回来以后的这边
那右侧交易要怎么进场
又有很多种
有的人是追突破的
有的人是像我们一样回来买的
不一样
但是这些通常都称之为右侧
这样子就是以最低点来当分界
所以如果你要看左右侧交易
除非在小10k里面
60分k里面这根线
这里才有惯性
下来上不去
有上去并且下不去
惯性改变
其实这几天框框就出来了
对吧
不用急啊
慢慢来就好
OK
国具的同学应该这样就可以了
好不好
好
然后
那个
Peter
其实你帮我讲的
我想讲的东西
我也要给这位
这位新同学
你说今天这样涨1600空军是不是死光了
应该这样讲
我先开台子棋出来
多军跟空军是
他是相对的
他应该讲说我们每个人
现在的多单就是未来的空单
现在的空单就是未来的多单
其实你要用这个角度去想
好
那我们来看
今天涨1600点
今天在这里从4300涨到4400
请问在这个上涨之前市场有没有早就暗示你好多他他下不去的迹象其实有哦今天有哦
尤其是日线来各位应该知道我很我很喜欢观察这种关键边界
对吧
而昨天的这个地方
就是应该讲前一天前一个交易日
他的那个点就大约是在底下的这个附近
这附近这样子那就很漂亮
那你说这边60k有没有好东西
其实有
好那说真的空军有没有死光
多军有没有死光
坦白讲跟我们的交易一点关系都没有
第一个是我们永远不可能知道
到底谁是空军谁是多军
然后谁死光了没
因为永远都可以有新的人进来
那也有也永远都有可能有
原本做多的人这一秒钟立刻跳槽
他本来做多他觉得不做了
赶快要变成空单
有啊
所以我们其实掌握不了这些
那为什么大家会养成习惯讲这些话
我觉得啦
可能平常的节目看多了
比较会会熟悉一些那种
帮市场给他定义的这种感觉
帮他们给他情绪
那有一种情形我可以告诉你
空军死光了
什么意思
例如说假设今天是这样子
一路涨
涨到这边狂喷
涨到49,000
甚至48,000这边应该就已经死光了
涨破边界还在涨
然后这天盘中的短线
冲冲冲冲冲
超级冲的这样子
那我大概就知道
所有的空军
如果是要结算
例如说像美股市三个月一次
或是台股市每个月一次
总之这个合约里面所做多或做空的人都死光了
这个我看得出来
你懂我意思吗
但是我就不会去在中间这种地方去看一根而已
如果以做空来讲
很多空在上面的人他没差
说不定可以等继续下面
那很多假设今天做空好了
他空失败了
也不过才1000多点
很多要凹的人还在凹
对啊
好不好
所以就不要管这件事好,那我们先看一下上面有几位同学的我记得我有些我有结在大家的问题里面
好,那我等一下有结晶问题的我就不直接回答
等一下问题那边回答
我这样看到什么就先聊什么
看到同学越来越稳定其实很开心
投資帳戶的資金
你可以試試看25、25、50可以我覺得沒有什麼問題
然後我去打球那個街外球我那天還戴補縮手套
原來平常沒有打棒球的其實看到那個球在飛
很難掌握那個軌跡原來是這樣因為我問我老婆他就眼睜睜看著球打到他的手
就這樣
等於說他也沒有閃
因為也不知道球真的會打到他
這樣
打出去的界外球會旋
會往外這樣子這個旋過去
我看到什麼就講什麼囉
9105昨天日線尖尖的買在8.46
來我們看一下
這套衣服跟上禮拜一樣
真的嗎
如果你這幾天有在路上遇到我
可能很大的几率都一样
我有两件非常类似的衣服
其实我的个性是希望我的衣柜都长一样
这样就不用挑了
但是我就会被我老婆骂
哎那个
你买在8.46
我的妈呀很漂亮的点
哇这个这个很漂亮
哎各位同学又来了
邊界出現尖尖的隔天就開始動
是不是各位買的啊
我真的太厲害了
我的資源有
來來來
資源在這邊剛好有
資源在
我那天不是吃這裡嗎
後面這裡跳空下來
啊達到我的成本下一些些
好啦出了
為什麼
因為我覺得
這邊理論上尤其經歷過這個
他應該上去
我先上
這樣 這個是我在做的事情
然後呢 但是你知道嗎
他打下來後的日線 這個日線其實
很漂亮 可惜啊
他們我這個沒有吃到
這樣
來上面好像還有同學問
1336 1336
台漢這是什麼呢
台漢
買在14.7
大家買點都很好耶
说真的大家都学会了
上边界下边界
然后在下边界的地方等市场停顿吃可以哦
然后今天涨停
漂亮哦
如果继续涨停就继续抱着啊
看他哪一天
假设他突然间某一天
跑到
假设到这里出现这种上影线
例如说当天冲上去到19
然后结果盘中很快的19
18.518.518.4啊赶快跑
就是他衝上去上不去
我變成長上引線
又出現在滿足區的地方
然後又出現在這裡
直接跑了啦
這就很棒
那除非你說你現在有
跟我說你有周線的計畫
到20你只願意走一半OK哦
OK
那你就繼續剩下的就承受大震盪
然後跟他繼續賭上去
賭到2426甚至28
我都覺得沒有什麼問題
我同學們很厲害
我覺得很厲害
然後
GRAB Grab
盤前已經上來了
我用這邊看好了
GRAB
他的日線
日線也不錯耶
周線也不錯耶
因為看日線大概就知道周線的樣子
这周线不错是不错
但是你心里要有个底
这边会停顿一段时间的几率比较高
原因是因为它左边这边
它有一段蛮长的
从4月到6月卡在这边的整理区域
所以理论上右边这边
如果这样子的宽度
其实对于市场来讲
其实会比较好
应该讲说如果同样的宽度
之后上去的时候那个比较好上去不然这边的卖压会一个个在压在这个地方简单的说如果你今天没吃到没关系慢慢来他会在这边震一下
这样子
记忆体每天上下午
还真的啊
真的是很调皮
是说真的
记忆体最近我都开始在吃了
这样
我不是吃在这
我是吃在那个
我自己的另外一个公司户那边
这样
多看一下还有什么呢
早上8点多的小娜
来来来
这个时间我正好载小孩子出门
我气到不行
一回家就没有了
我就送小孩子去夏令营
然后回来
哇没得吃
我回来的点大概在这里
我就直接关电脑不看
你知道吗
所以后面这些位置啊什么的
我完全都没有看
我就不理他了
所以今天就这样
我觉得很好吃的点
其实是这个
60K
60K的大边界
然后5K还可以长一大堆下引线
那边真的很美
但是我人不在盘前
就这样子吧
暑假我觉得
好像每年的暑假
如果各位知道
我的玩心会比较重
然後小孩子在家嘛
所以我也會比較多時間
就是反正就處理各種家裡的事情
陪小孩玩等等
好不好
送虛擬寶石
剛剛好像我同學有送東西耶
不要不要不要不要不要送我啦
不要送我啦
特斯拉
特斯拉我的確會有考慮加
我今天的確就考慮要加了
沒事別亂生真的
沒事別亂生
600 690 買在20.18
今天22出了一半
來我看一下好了
這個應該是中國的股票
看一下600 690
你買的很漂亮啊
來先不要管
先不要管會不會標
你买的点很漂亮啊
这个是举双手赞成的漂亮
很棒很棒
然后一买就是标股如果是一个月後你才買了幾天而已對吧這個
你不要想那麼多啦
你買的點很漂亮的
這個日線很漂亮
你在22這裡出了一些很好啊
這個出法是很標準的出一流一的這種動作
很好很好
如果一個月後他整理又噴到這裡
這樣不少耶對吧
所以不要覺得不好
他需要时间
所以你给他时间
他会好好的去走给你看的
那如果我是你
我觉得我会很轻松的抱着
而且他之前其实也有潜力可以走成这样子
那你买的点就这么漂亮
买在这个边界
这边你竟然出了一半了
剩下一半就不要理他
就让他飘
怎么飘都不要理他
了不起成本就给你
怎么飘都不理他
这样
然后就赌
赌他会再上去
这样子
恭喜你SR同學讚
這個問題我就拿來當作準備要開場的東西
有同學問說尖尖的下面的隔壁池
通常應該在什麼時候是有時候一個紅棒就慢慢上去了
你知道這個問題是結果論嗎
因為有些時候出現這根收定可能是5分K
收定了以後隔壁開始出現晃啊晃
結果沒兩下就上去了
但是也會出現晃啊晃
結果盤中是先往下殺
然後殺了這個地方你可能已經被停損掉了
結果尾盤就是這一根的尾盤才往上收
結果變這樣然後才又收回去
那你到底是要在這一開始買還是在後面買
我沒有辦法知道哪個好哪個壞
這樣講好了
如果他剛開始其實你可以稍微等一下
因為沒有到急到一定要在第一秒鐘
一開的第一秒鐘就給他下
如果是股票來我先講股票
股票日線出現尖尖的日線出現尖尖的
隔壁這一天你可以分階段
例如說一開盤
你先試個1%的部位試試看
先試水溫中間如果下來沒有真的跌破大邊界大边界那尾盘注意哦当天的尾盘例如说中午12点你吃饭的时候
看了一下
当天的尾盘准备收上去
所以让这个的日线也收了一个这样子的
哦
那如果你本来准备吃
十分之三的部位
刚刚已经吃了十分之一的嘛
对不对早上先吃的
那你看到尾盘
出现这样子尾盘收上去了
再把剩下的十分之二的部位补进去
那你就是这一天就是吃了三成的资金
好这样可以
这样
我喜欢的是尾盘这边如果动能上来
代表我几乎是紧接着后面的力量
然后明天有可能继续往这边走
所以我喜欢这种
包含在五分K在十五分K的概念也都是一样的
把我刚刚讲的这件事情换成大颗度的边界
5分K的尖尖的5分K的隔壁
晃啊晃啊晃啊晃
本来这像是隔壁根哦
前一根是尖尖的
隔壁晃啊晃啊晃啊晃
下不去下不去就开始有点往上
好吃
这时候会留下一个5分K差不多要收下引线的样子
那从我的经验下引线越多
向前越多
后面上去的几率就越高
那上去的那个距离也越远
这样子
好不好
好来
那我就
我就来讲今天的课程
来今天的课程是这个
我们上个礼拜讲蛮多技术面的东西
今天稍微偏一点心态
因为我认为
纯技术跟纯心态两边都不是很好
你需要综合两件事情
那今天来聊的是
如何克服恐惧跟贪婪
也来聊如何稳定的获利
好
那我们就开始
那这个问题解答会先摆在前面
这个是我刚刚在看到几个同学的
国具刚刚讲过了
就直接跳过
那这位同学的
我刚好也讲到了
来我要给这位拜托别停损同学
不是拜托别订阅我在讲什么
你说你做美股是日线搭配周线
如果日K有标准图的地方
你想要到小时可以找成本比较低
那防守是要守护
我跟妳說
如果妳進到小顆度
60分K去找成本低的地方
妳就是守60K
不要這樣子喔
不要進到小顆度吃
卻跑到大顆度防守
因為
來我舉個例子
我用比較極端一點的來當例子
假設
我進到小顆度
我小顆度吃在這裡
當然這不是值得吃多單的點 但是我只是借我舉例 就當下
假設我小顆都吃在這 那我理論上我該防守的點就是這裡而已 對吧
不能說老魚老魚 我可不可以在1K進場 然後看著15K
15K的這裡來當風險 我守這裡 不行
因為這樣下來你會承受第一個過多的風險
第二你整套交易计划已经跟原来的完全不一样
如果你要做日线单
那你就是在
在日线的边界
假装这是日线好不好
你就是在日线的边界
同时间也是60分k的边界
这里面去找60分k的破底翻
又回到我们一开始教的东西
你去找这个
这条线同时间也是60k的边界
也是日K的边界
一举两得
你吃短线
但是同时间两个都可以防守
哇这个赞
这样听得懂那个想法吗
好不好
我相信你懂了
因为你应该是老同学了
所以守小时K就好
如果要守日线
除非它两个重叠才能守日线
来
再來這是在網友
他寫信到那個老魚的金融筆記
各位有問題其實可以寫
只是因為裡面的來信
就是大家的來信都會寫
我不見得可以立刻看得到你的訊息
我會盡量的去看你的東西
好不好
那有同學問說
如果每天都要等這個
白天要上班會錯過一些行情
可能一天都沒有一次
來我跟你說
如果你白天要上班会错过那白天错过的地方就是你应该就要错过的你这辈子怎么样只要你要白天要上班你那个行情你就是那就不是你要做的事情
谁叫你白天要上班
你就很宽心的把它放掉
那本来就不是我的
这样好不好
这是第一件事情
第二个
如果你说一天都没有出手于是
的确这样盘感也没练到
你可以适当的去用那个Tradle V
我直接
我用这个
我找一个影片给大家
你照着这支影片
这支
照着这支
我之前录的
你搜寻标题
如何利用10分钟信箱
注册Tradleway免费账号
用重播来replay
好不好
用这个
影片
然后呢
你用那个来干嘛
来做重播的练习
好不好
因为他可以把
把那个
五天内的盘面
五个日历天
包含礼拜六礼拜日
简单的说
像现在
礼拜三就只能播一二三
上礼拜四五播不到
大概就是这样
他可以把你错过的盘面
拿回来做肌肉记忆的练习
但是你不能先偷看
你要去练那个
你不知道走势的行情才有意义
然后你就把它拿来
用四个小时的倍数
四倍数的方式去播
我里面有讲解怎么练
这是一种练法
第二种练法也是利用replay
是你明明知道
例如说
例如说我明明知道有一个破底翻
很美
然后后面上去了
对不对
我明知道这样子
你就故意去把这个破底分打个好几次
打个三次
把时间叫出来
从准备下沙的时间点下来
等吃
吃到爆完
好
这样一趟
大概会花你一个小时
第一趟
第二趟就加快速度了
反正这边你都知道怎么做
下来
吃
然后吃到以后就去旁边做别的事
养成习惯
吃到以後 設好停損去旁邊做別的事
然後這時候單子會自己跑跑到你要的搓力了結的點就把它除掉好兩次三次總共加起來大概會花你一個小時所以一個晚上你可以練固定的這個吃的動作練三次
一個禮拜你就練平日的晚上就好
如果你每天都很忙都沒有辦法下到單
用這種方式去練練那個肌肉記憶
然後下個禮拜的某一天你在看盤的時候
你會突然間哎呦
你一定感受过我讲的这件事情
我调查一下好不好
因为现在刚好线上有494个同学
有这样练过的举手
让我知道一下
然后这样练完是不是真的有用
是不是真的可以看到行情
你的直觉你的眼睛就
这个我认得
这样
那这个是用replay的两种练法
好不好 举手真的有用 很有用
对吧 对吧
你在练的当下你会觉得很讶异
就是我明知他长上去 我转着干嘛
对 你会这样子问自己
但是你一个礼拜后
你根本不记得你上个礼拜练过什么
睡到一半 看一下盘后马上跳起来打蛋
所以你就是把一些
哇 那个一看就是很标准的点
就把它拿回来打
这样一天花一个小时就好了
就那一个小时
然后其他时间就不用在盘面上
如果你很忙
你连下增仓的什么都不用
然后你就是这样子
你就练一个礼拜
如果你能够坚持一个月
每天都做一件这件事情
今天刚好看到原油有好点
我要打他一下
明天看到黄金有好点
打他一下
后天是小奈有好点
你去这样子练那个肌肉记忆
我可以保证
这个我可以保证
真的有用
好不好
同学旁边好多人
大家可以看一下旁边的
这是各位的见证
这样子
OK
来
底下这个
我认为
我都要把这个拿在前面讲
我之所以还没讲政客其实这些也是心态面的东西
同学说他的账号
出金4400先恭喜出金很棒然后就完全乱掉自信心爆棚把账号打爆太棒了因为你走了一条大家都走过的路
我们每个人都是在赚很多钱的时候
然后突然间从天堂就掉到谷底
因为那一瞬间你的屁股就翘起来
就觉得我最强
所以恭喜你经历了大家都经历的事情
我一点都不意外
好不好
有人说他的过程走了很多次
但是哦
你爆掉了嘛对不对
疯狂刷卡买账号一个都没通关
这个也是很多人都走过的
好
到了六月下定决心
只有一个账号很速力通关
达到三千多
因为一致性不能立刻出金
活一个月又爆掉
好
来
你知道自己活该打法有问题
摸起术后有点不爽
等到一个好位置摸一次大单考回来
失去初衷了对不对
我跟你说
所有在这个循环的同学
你就放宽心的给他乱
我并没有打算把你调回来
因为你还赔不够多
你的卡刷的还不够多不够痛
我不是来讲干话的
因为在这个时候我阻止你其实没有用
你在那个当下
那个很想下单的当下
就算是你老公老婆拦着你都没有用
只要你户头有钱
信用卡一刷
账号立刻就有了
所以靠回来也过关了
是需要你一直到
突然间看到你的刷卡记录
才发现
我这个月怎么刷这么多
对
我要等到你那样叹气的时候
这个时候我们旁边的人讲的话
你才听得进去
你才会开始回头反省自己
我在干嘛
如果没有到那个点
四次你会醒不过来
这我已经讲了十几年
在这边讲这样子的课程
还是会一直遇到类似的样子
那你说
有没有方法可以
有待会后面其实会有
后面有
所以我留到后面一起讲
这样好不好
我只是先跟这位同学说其实
你能够出金代表你一定做对某些事
所以你现在最好的事情是先
要去考试
你去把你当初通关的那个账号的记录给叫出来
然后也把你爆掉那段时间的记录给叫出来
你两个记录一打开
数据叫出来一看
很清楚
你很清楚知道你自己做了什么
对跟错的事
那你就要跟自己保证了
好
我老于今天重新开始
那我对着镜子说
你今天要遵守
所有的纪律跟规矩
不能乱打蛋
最多亏到哪里就收工
甚至你要把这段话
白纸黑字的写下来贴在荧幕旁边
都可以
好
TraderFi里面没有月曆的损益
那个是在
TraderFi那边才有
就是它是在所有外面的这些
考试的公司
这种自营商考试的公司
他们的系统你才有
他们才做的网页
把资料丢到那边去
然后用这样的方式呈现给你
好不好
每次差一个三五百通关
心情都会乱掉
来我跟你说
给这位尤其是这种
静观情怯的同学
我建议你
把差多少钱通关或不通关
这件事情先忘记
我讲是一回事
但是真的要忘真的有点难
但是本质上你就是要想办法把它忘记
你每天在市场上要记录的东西
不是赚赔
不是赚多少钱赔多少钱
是记我今天正确的乖乖的出手几次
乱七八糟的出手几次
要记这个
然后正确出手记赚赔
错误的出手记赚赔
OK
但是重点要摆在我的出手
有没有照着我的计划做
曾经有位同学打台子旗
我都还不知道他怎么打单
他跟我说他打单亏亏亏亏亏
然后他就丢了他的交易记录
他的交易记录是一个很详细的Excel表
一位我记得是姓黄的同学
Excel表上面写的
7月1号台子旗打了哪些单子
哪一个价格近
哪一个价格出
赚赔多少点
第二单哪一个价格近
哪一个价格出
赚赔多少点
然后7月1号整天的损益
在这边
7月2号整天的损益在这边7月3号正负多少点所以他可以口头跟我讲得出来 老姨我昨天赚43点我前天输25点 他会讲得出点数来
然后他的部位一直赔
然后我只帮他做一件事
我说你从今天开始
完全不要记损益 你赚几点
多少点都不知道
对 你不知道你赚多少点
我就是请他把焦点拉回来
到他原来的交易计划上
然后他下个月就传讯息给我了
那个时候我还在带群组 他也是群组同学
应该有一些同学有跟他重叠到的
他就传讯息给我 跟我说 他开始变赚钱了 获利的这样子
我什么事都没做
我甚至没有很明确的知道他什么交易法都不重要
我只是把钱抽离而已 他就赚钱了
好不好
来
这个是有一位同学说恐惧贪婪
大家分不清楚什么时候该恐惧该贪婪吗
某个程度对
但也不对
这个待会也会讲
我用这位同学的问题来回答一个东西
同学说
他这个代码我记得
他后来给我更新的
好像是这个
HC1的这个
来
这张图我先不看你的文字
我第一秒钟看到的是
这是下源
对吧
这是上缘
这是下缘
我就画这两条线
所以我怎么样也不会在这个地方
想要做空
对不对
所以你说
看一下大图是空头满足区还对
下的有出所也只敢做一口玩玩
等一下
所以你想要小10k上面
等好的结构
你是想要在这里
你想要做空吗
这是你想要做空的吗
如果我是你
小10k这边
可以啊
你在这个地方空
坦白讲没有到很漂亮
但是风险也不大
只不过你心里要有底
你是在大的满足区的地方在这里做空
所以要是这边稍微起来
你至少拉个不赔
你要继续赌下去可以
但是至少拉个不赔
这样子
好吗
关于交易记录怎么写
我记得Jack那边有一份很棒的交易记录
我去找一下
我记得在他的YouTube频道上面有影片说教育记录怎么写
来所以这位同学我会怎么处理当前的状况第一个
我只做一边
我不会做多又做空
我的脑袋没有那么厉害
我承认我很烂
我承认我的脑容量很小
所以多单跟空单
我选一个做
如果你只要做空单
那你的空单就要评估了
你的空单
你要做假突破的空单
那这张图
它发生在大刻度的下缘
比较容易成功
还是发生在
在长不上去的地方
人做多的满足区的地方
然后上不去的地方
这个地方比较容易做
我没有画得很精准
我只是在表达那个概念
所以你心中就要有个底
你的位阶在哪里
然后你要做什么事情
所以你问我当下我会怎么做
如果我要做多很好啊
但是不是現在做
現在卡在中間
我就是畫出兩條線
Linbei在下面等你
我就看他在下面怎麼做
這樣
好不好
來
我們來開始來聊
哇今天畫了20分鐘回答問題
因為其實大家問題其實蠻多的
剛剛看到旁邊有人說
那個3000
你知道吗 我看过一些网友
一个月花20万台币 30万台币在刷卡
买这种账号
他们买账号是5个10个 5个10个这样子买
然后再拼那个出金这样
我觉得好了 给你拼到了 你就赌博
反正就赌看某个账号上去
拼到了的确 可以cover你的成本
但是你敢保证你每一个月都可以拼得到吗
如果你每个月
如果你某个月拼不到
刷卡的咖啡还是要嚼
这个
我是完全不推荐这样子的模式
我觉得你就乖乖的正常的下单就好
看到臭豆腐
可恶我也有点饿
来了
从第一句话开始
我们越在乎某一件事
越会感到恐惧跟贪婪
什么意思
你在乎你的生命
所以你会对你会害怕失去生命
也希望有更多一点维持生命的东西对吗所以你越在乎的东西就会这样子然后呢先从一个故事来讲解这个恐惧跟贪婪
我有一个朋友现实生活中的朋友
他前一段时间在五月六月就是台股
在很高的台积电在25000
然后创新高大概就是国具1200的那附近
然后他跟我说他也去借钱
他也去信贷身上都没有存款
存款全部都押進去股市
然後他每個月的收入一進來就是拿來繳房貸
繳完剩下一些生活費幾乎就空空的
沒有備用資金幾乎都是都是沒有的
來
你覺得從恐懼的角度看他在怕什麼
大家想一下他怕什麼為什麼他要
存款去買股票還不夠還信貸買股票
然後身上所有的現金都拿進去
不留什么现金在身上
你觉得他在怕什么东西呢
再再看
嗯没错
怕赚不到钱
尤其是他应该怕的是怕什么
怕前一段时间
大家都在赚钱的时候
那时候他的确没赚到
他怕又发生同样的情形
又被丢在后面好像
好像阿呆一样
大家都在赚
啊我没有赚的
插鞋筒都开鞋店了
對不對?沒有,現在插鞋桶的鞋墊倒掉了,你知道嗎?
對吧?在前兩天倒掉了
然後現在才要重新開帳
我們不需要去追人家的東西
但是在市場上面很自然而然會去看大家在賺錢
然後自己沒賺到
我覺得他這樣很危險
因為他是在最高點那個時候開槓桿
他还问我说老鱼你会借钱投资吗
我说我不会
我不去借钱投资的
我都是用闲钱这样
虽然期货本身
他其实就是带着很强的杠杆
但是我的期货
我的风险是手好好的
对吧
好继续
他害怕错过
所以他在高点买
你身边最近在网路上
是不是看到一大堆国具赔钱的案例
然后什么的案例
对不对
然后大家在写文的时候
其实有些人的文章里面会看得出来
这个受害者的经验
他会开始站在可能是政府害的
可能是外资害的
可能是谁害的
谁害的
可能是那个老板害的
那个老板不诚信什么的
反正通通都不是他自己凹丹害的
都是别人害他赔钱
所以我们如果很常把这种错怪在外界
那其实坦白讲在市场上面
你会永远当这个受害者
老天爷就会认为说
老鱼你这么喜欢当受害者
你每天都在觉得自己很可怜
好,那我就多给你一点可怜的事情
你这么爱哦,给你
对啊
所以我都觉得
觉得
那些人发文
其实我很同情他们
但是就是要受过这种伤
然后吸取教训
才有办法回头试案
但是有些人是不吸取教训
就继续就一直这样子
那他的钱就是永远变成韭菜都不见
然后我也会收到一些网友的私讯
老鱼
我知道不能凹单
但是我总是停不下来
怎么办
大概平均一个礼拜会有一则类似的心态的私讯
这种我不见得会回来
很难回太多了
这样
你知道解法
我讲到这个讲到烂掉
解法就是你的问题
你总是凹单
那就不要凹
你总是过度交易
警察先生对不起
我总是闯红灯
我总是忍不住闯红灯
对吧
这句话听起来真的很好笑
前一阵子很多大学股神
有啊
韩国不是还有一个台币大概四十几万
翻成台币六百万
然后现在又归零
我刚才看到新闻而已啊
有没有
就是
就都是这样开杠杆
然后他最后一句话我记得
他说他仍然会使用融资
仍然会开杠杆
好吧请便
代表他开的还不够
跌的不够深
来
其实我
我标题使用克服这两个字
这其实是一个陷阱
我们人这辈子永远克服不了恐惧跟贪婪
它是根深蒂固烙印在我们骨子里面的本来的情绪你一定会有恐惧跟贪婪的事实上恐惧跟贪婪是在保护你的
对吧
你害怕失去这个东西
所以你会抓得紧紧的
然后贪婪是你有更多
你就可以活得下去的金钱
对吧
那真正要做的事情
不是克制它
也不是克服它
是跟恐惧与贪婪和平共处
等一下后面会聊
怎么和平共处
我们可以借由冥想
静坐
深呼吸
对着镜子跟自己讲话
其实我很喜欢这样子
闲闲没事做
就坐在那边也不是滑手机
可能就是只是放空
看着海
看着山
看着风景
然后就每次做放在那边
就享受那个当下
就这样就好了
所以我们可以藉由这样子的时间
多了解自己
然后把外面的事情
焦点拉回来自己身上
因为在静坐跟冥想
都一个很重要的点
他们都说要关注自己的呼吸
闭上眼睛
然后把焦点放在呼吸上
吸气 吐气
外面的事情都外面的事情
对不对
在这个过程中你会慢慢习惯
注意哦
你会习惯把外界的事情
画一条防火墙
在这个防火墙以内
是我的内心世界
外界的纷纷扰扰进不来
一开始你的防火墙可能还有点薄
有点一下子就被撞倒了
没有关系
再练习再练习
越来越后越来越后
最后厚到跟柏林围墙一样
一开始是推不倒的
对不对
所以你要慢慢的养成习惯
让外界的东西不要进来
今天才有一个同学
我刚刚才回他而已
应该是
应该是AdWords是不是
我忘记了
总是一个同学才问我说
如果他给小费
对方的脸臭臭的怎么办
我给他小费是我爽就好
爽是爽在我自己
他如果我给他
他脸还是臭
他是臭他自己
你管他咧
对不对
这样就好了
但是我前面讲的这些冥想静坐深呼吸如果你是像黄翔建设这样子很有钱但我没说他们不用静坐不用冥想
他就凹吧
是说他真的很厉害
他均价是在1186
然后7月1号正好是国具冲上1220块的地方
他的均价几乎是那个价格
我不得不去看一下国具的图
国具在这里
我只能说他真的厉害
应该讲说这个就是他买上去的
那是谁卖给他的
你要想一下
对吧
我是学佛的吗
也不算
我不算学佛
也不算基督徒
我什么都没有
但是我就是
我很喜欢这种概念
就是把焦点拉回自己身上的概念
好不好
那我觉得他
来有些人底下这里会说
还以为只有我们被套
这下心理平衡了
来我跟你说
公司套跟个人套完全不一样
这间公司套牢了
他赔的了不起是公司的钱
老板照样吃香喝辣没有差
对吧
但是如果是个人套牢
也都不一样
钱就套牢了
而且如果人家是
有好多亿
然后才套个几千万
或套个三亿五亿
人家假设有五百亿
然后套个五亿
不要讲五百亿
有连二十亿套个五亿
他也没感觉
你现在不相信
我就算是个人
所以
那个资金的多寡
其实有差
大户
人家大户有能力拗
我们没能力拗
对
来
但是你看喔
我刚刚讲这些
前面静坐冥想深呼吸
网路上会有一群人
他们会认为
在做这些事情是怪力乱神
就是要卖开运水
开运手环
有没有
的邪教这样子
讲这些都是心灵机当中骗人的
有一群人是有这种想法
那或许他们的生活会觉得
例如说吸引力法则都很烂
最好是讲一讲想一想钱就会来
当他这样子在想的时候
其实他是带着有刺的这个眼的这个语气在看世界戴着有色的眼镜在看世界所以他不管怎么样看
他的世界都是戴着一层墨镜的
他永远看不到真正的东西
坦白讲这一群人
我会觉得他们有点可惜跟可怜
因为他一直过不来
所以他只好用一个
一个把你拉起来也好
或是用一个很负面的角度
看待这个世界
那我们运气好
可能有老天爷帮我们点开来
我们看到原来正向的世界
讲好话的世界
是这么不错的
所以我们看到的世界
就完全不同的东西
这样好不好
然后呢
我刚刚前面这边讲
说有些人会说这些
这些东西是来玩的
是骗人的对不对
来这个是谁
对不起我只会截取
我的那个年代
我认得的球星
现在新的我可能要截取哈兰德
跟
我儿子很爱哈兰德
Jack的开运水
Coby来看一下
这是我从Coby的YouTube的截图
看一下Coby的
Coby Bryan
The Power of Meditation
冥想的力量
他说他每天
都在早上冥想个
10 15分钟
他的影片自己搜寻这个标题就有了
Coby每天做
他觉得这个可以帮助他
准备好他的一天
大家还记不记得
之前世界
WBC的时候
陈杰倩打出全铁打
那个三分炮的时候
他在打击区前面他是不是闭着眼睛
他就是在想象那个样子
他也在冷静
然后呢
这些运动员们他们都在做这些事情
这位有没有人光看名字就知道他是谁的
他说Train your body, Train your mind
练你的身体也练你的脑袋
冥想到睡着正常就给他睡
没有关系睡起来很舒服这样就好
我是很认真你不用去抗拒他
你一定会冥想到睡着就给他睡
这是我们侨王的对
网球名将
我直接叫AI帮我整理的摘要
每天冥想多少?10年
他认为这是他关键的因素
心理跟生理并重
各位你觉得交易不需要心理吗?
交易超需要心理上面的稳定好不好?超级需要
对我来讲在市场上就好像打仗一样
所以我如果能够在战场上面越冷静
我就不会被市场上面的纷扰给吸走
我就可以冷静在旁边
看到我要的机会 把部位敲进去这样子
所以这是他说的
然后底下这里我还找了一位这个Michael Jordan
这个我就叫AI帮我找啊
你看他找了一位将佛教禅修与静坐引入球队的训练
有没有注意看哦
他说进入所谓的The Zone
对他们在国外他们讲那个Zone
然后不受过去失败或未来担忧的干扰
注意担忧未来是不是就是害怕
害怕什么
害怕做错怎么办
害怕投不进怎么办
害怕打不出去怎么办
害怕下单就停损怎么办
就停损
你下单就是会停损
它就是交易的一部分
你不可能回避停损
然后只要赚利润不可能
然后他也说不受过去的失败
我前一球是前一球的事情
下一球是新的
我就好好专注在那里
当下
是吧
所以我现在举的这些都是
这些是我那个年代的运动员
我相信到这个年代
也还是有很多运动员都很强调这一块
甚至这个年代越来越多
这个冥想跟静坐的变成显学
连Netflix里面都有一部
冥想静坐指南
我那部真的很推荐大家去看
好不好
你就照着做
把每一集他叫你做的事情
你就在电视前面照着做
做完真的会有用
好吗
都是我爸爸那个年代
对对对也是我爸爸的年代
因为是我小时候
Michael Jordan活跃的时候
公牛很活跃
很活跃的时候
是我很小时候
国小吧
在电视机前面看的时候那我们要开始来聊我们的大脑其实可以训练你记得你第一次开车吗
第一次上高速公路的样子吗
很恐怖对不对
那个汇入渣道的样子
后面的车一直来怎么办
怎么办
牵不进去
有没有
你现在呢
习入就直接进到内线
不是吗
那为什么你第一次很害怕
现在却不害怕
这中间差别在哪里
在于练习的次数
对吧
那你说第一次赔钱很恐惧
现在呢
你现在更不怕
因为你是已经赔到麻痹了
对不对
赔到麻痹有很多种
一种是好的
你很宽心的接受
他就是有赚赚跟赔赔
另外一种赔到麻痹
是他赔大的
赔过30万
赔3万就没感觉
赔过300万
赔30万就没感觉
你大概是这样子
但是这种不好
你只会越赔越多而已
我不是很常开车吗
你在你妈妈下的钥匙
因为不是大开车
但是你看
你每天喂给大脑什么东西
你的大脑很厉害
最近有很多研究都已经有明确的记录
人的大脑就算40岁50岁60岁70岁
都还是可以学新的东西
做出新的事情来
所以你一直喂给他
他就会变得很在行很熟悉
所以你每天看的讯息
今天羡慕一次
脑袋被刺激
羡慕的感觉一次
明天又刺激一次
早中晚一直在看
他赚钱好棒
你怎么赚的
你一直在羡慕嘛
羡慕久了
你的脑袋就会养成一个
很会羡慕人家的那种感觉
所以你就会越来越贪
因为越羡慕就会越贪嘛
你越不羡慕代表你很知足
你觉得我这样就够了
所以你就不会去羡慕别人
那这时候你就可以把焦点拉回来
有没有
有人说你的阿公很固执
给他正确思维还有救吗
没有救
第一个是改变别人这件事本质上真的很难
第二你要改变的如果是阿公阿公等级的他连他自己儿子的话都不会听了更不用讲孙子的话了你就放宽心吧
这个没有办法
你就跟你阿公和平共处
开开心心的这样就好了
就改不了了
好不好
就是这样子
改自己就好
第一次去抓眼镜蛇
7月初有同事还在追高突破
还不到7月底本金已经负50%
现在每天都认证上班
冥想要想什么
冥想不是想钱
很多人认为说这个冥想
例如说他冥想不是想钱
每个运动的冥想可能会有点不太一样
但是他们在想的东西
有一大部分是让自己的脑袋静下来
因为例如说你要上场比赛好了
你要打棒球
你要打篮球
你脑袋有千言万语
我到底要这样投好
做这个战术好吗
还是打棒球
我要锁定曲球
还是锁定直球
还是我要怎么样怎么样怎么样
哇剧本一大堆
脑袋乱糟糟
所以他们有一大部分的目的
是让乱糟糟的脑袋
来深呼吸
回到我原来该做的事情
市场上纷纷扰扰的东西都不重要
回来到我
只剩下我跟小娜
小娜出现什么样子
我要做什么事
只剩下我跟她
好
慢慢回到只有我跟这个球场
这样子
他们一大部分是这个
第二种
他们是很冷静的在脑袋里面
模拟整场的比赛
我上次看过一个
一个很厉害的赛车选手
F1的赛车选手
他坐在旁边休息的时候
眼睛闭着
然后耳朵听着那个F1赛车
他们实际上跑在跑道上面的录音
然后就跟着这样
然后再切换那个排档
我不知道大家有没有看过那个影片
就假装在开车
然后脚也跟着在踩
然后还可以排档
还可以干嘛这样
他们在脑袋里面是模拟
球来的时候我要怎么打
模拟场上的状况来的时候我要怎么做好等他真的上场的时候他其实在脑袋里已经模拟一千次一万次了
所以他上场的时候一点都不慌
因为他已经做过这样子的事情很多遍
这个动作其实
他在欺骗自己的脑袋
因为你相信我们眼前看到的这些世界
这些东西都只是视觉上面
视神经的讯号
各位现在看到的萤幕跟听到我的声音
只是耳朵听到的神经的讯号
跟视神经的视觉讯号
你怎么知道你不是活在一个matrix
骇客任务里面
你怎么知道
我们不知道啊
对吧
所以当你可以在脑袋里面
去想象各种东西的时候
其实你的脑袋也跟着走了一遍
你该要刺激的神经也都被刺激了一遍
所以我们可以用正向的方式来训练
而不是一直为给他恐惧跟贪婪
为给他嫉妒
羡慕
或是有些人是骂的东西
骂人
骂很凶
愤怒
这都不用
来
怎么开始改变
做一件事情
很简单的事情
你可以在你的日历或是手机的日历
或是实体上面
券商都会送你
送你那个桌历对不对
你就准备红绿灯
红笔跟蓝笔就好了
然后呢
你每天固定一个时间
例如说固定每天晚上
然后晚上六点
或是晚上九点睡觉前
我们不会那么早睡了
反正是固定一个时间
评估一下来
我今天一整天的情绪是什么
我今天其实
闷闷的
原来是小朋友跟我吵架了
怎么样怎么样
好
涂个红色
今天一整天都不错
好涂个蓝色
或是今天我在交易上面的情绪
哇我今天整个大培很不爽
涂个红色
你用这种方式
会不知不觉练习着
抽离在天空上面
往下看老于现在自己的情绪
给这位问冥想的同学
请你去找内部那个冥想之内
我刚刚讲Netflix里面的内部
把它找来看
好不好
他里面有很详细
我这边讲不完
他有很详细的步骤
你就跟着他做
每一集都把它看
我记得是八集而已
把它看完
好不好
所以你就记录自己的情绪
那你看
我这样调查好了
你今天一整天
你有用第三人生的角度
来看你自己的情绪的举手
今天应该很少
大部分的人都是
生活来了
事情来了就是把这个事情处理完
就是一直埋在那个事情里面
就一直走一直走
一直走到睡觉
对吧几乎都是这样
对吧但如果你能够
开始告诉自己
我每天都要画红绿灯
今天是绿灯
明天是红灯好
对吧如果你可以
每天都给自己的情绪贴一个标签
你会慢慢养成
对
察觉自己的心
察觉自己现在
情绪的那个刻度状态
的那个感觉
你会越来越厉害
所以以前的我
在看盘的时候
现在情绪里面
那个盘跑很快
例如说
如果我把旁边的那个
五档下单
十档下单叫出来
盘跑好快
然后你会被他吸走
跳来跳去
但是你習慣以後
你會比較早可以跳脫開來
比較早醒過來
原來我被吸進去
趕快離開電腦
趕快去洗個澡
趕快做點別的事情
我被吸進去了
這樣
你過一段時間又被吸進去了
沒關係
你可能跳出來的時間也比較快
所以會慢慢慢慢養成這個習慣
每一集都睡著
我跟你说睡着是正常
因为你眼睛闭着照着他的座
你坐着坐着自然会睡着
慢慢的你会开始处在一个中间的地步
就是要睡不睡
这个我很难跟你解释
你要亲身经历过才知道
就是你很清楚知道自己在冥想
然后你也很清楚知道
自己也没有很认真在想事情
那好像又睡着了
大概
我真的很难说你自己练过你要练到一段时间你会经历过我现在讲的这一段就是要睡不睡有点清醒但是有点睡觉的样子
我在很多年前的直播
其实我也讲过这个
我也是用这个图
所以我很喜欢古一这一段
就是它是用第三人称的角度
灵魂浮在上面
像幽柱一样
在上面看着幽柱的身体
在底下
我讲到幽住
对年纪又出来了
对不对
早上起来都迟到
来我跟你说
如果你真的冥想会这样子的
你试着练习一种叫做
睁开眼睛的冥想
就是有点是
就是发呆啦
简单的说就是发呆
就是你就坐在这边
然后也不要看行情
什么事都不做
你的萤幕是黑的也没关系
或是萤幕
或是你就叫一幅风景画的萤幕
就坐在这里这样子
然后你就看着那幅风景
山啊海啊流水啊都可以
然后就这样子
然后就盯着他
什么事都不要做
然后就开始呼吸
眼睛张开哦张开哦这样
甚至有些时候我在开车的时候
我会开车的时候的
放空吗
也不算
有在开车一定知道我在讲的那种感觉
例如说你开到一段很没有车的高速公路
很舒服
你就这样开着听着音乐
那样子某个程度来说
其实你的脑袋也开始在把注意力拉回自己身上
静坐冥想最终最终的目的
是把注意力拉回自己身上
然后把外界的这样开始隔离
开到不知道怎么下交流道
我教小孩有啊
但是其实我觉得小孩的
他们可能时间点还没到吧
或是他们经历的事情还不够
然后或是他们脑袋里
跟针对情绪的这块的神经
例如说年纪本来就还不到
那个神经就还没有长好
有点似懂非懂
所以他们的情绪的控制
我觉得我不会要求太多
但是我会讲
我最常讲的就跟我儿子讲说
你很生气
你的脑袋会爆炸
会有那个脑细胞会死掉然后就翻那个医学的文章给他看你看生气的时候会脑中风哦呵呵呵这样对
念头跟情绪哦
对是自然而然会发生的没错
学着去切割它
啊这些动作哦
你
察觉久了
你才有办法在背后
开始
开始去理出
哦
用第三者的角度去看那个情绪哦
原来这个情绪是这样
这个念头是这样子
我会有这个厌恶的感觉
是因为我有这个念头
你就开始
很操然的角度看你自己
但是你看
光有平稳的情绪
没有固定的方法
其实还是一样
我情绪很稳
但是我不知道该怎么做
所以你一进到盘面的瞬间
那个稳定的情绪就不见了
因为你慌了
然后你就开始找方法
而且你是越快找方法越好
所以会有一些网友留言给我的时候很急
老鱼在吗
然后我可能没有回
10分钟后
老鱼这次股票这样子好吗
可以请你讲一下吗
然后10分钟没有回
老鱼有在吗
一直敲一直敲一直敲
我看到这个我就
坦白讲我会觉得
有点恐怖
因为我的第一步
就是我要先把气隔开来
他的气好急哦
我不能让那个急的气沾到我这边来
你相信吗隔着一幕哦
我都有可能被那个气给吸走
尤其是那种很急的人的气
他隔着一幕的那个感觉
那个气势的强大
很容易把我吸进去
所以我就跟着他一起急
跟着他一起愤怒一起干嘛
坏事传千里大概就是这种感觉
所以你还是要有一个明确
而且固定的判断逻辑
你才有办法坐在盘面上
例如说最近有人问我说
老于你为什么不做空
或是说有人问题是
老于我觉得我想要在这边
等到这个地方做多
然后看到这个地方做空
你觉得这样好吗
像我我刚刚不是讲吗
我直接承认我的脑袋很烂
所以我不想要给他很多事情做
我是个很烂很烂的脑袋所以他只能用一点点的力量而已那我就把他仅剩的这个脑容量留给多单
那我就只做多单就好
空单要干嘛那他家的事
反正我负责出场
然后出场之后就干嘛
就不关我的事啦
空单要怎么地方要做那是他家的事
我就不做了
你知道吗
自从我只做多单以后
我的绩效居然比多空都做来得好太多了
太多太多
然后以前的我一开始是多单也做空单也做
我这里可以做多那你可以做空
我脑袋中想象的是做上去又做回来
结果实际上是这边被停损了
上面又做又被停损一次那才又下来
所以我不止两个都没赚到
我还两个都赔到这样
所以我把自己搞的情緒又亂七八糟
很急躁手心冒汗
貼螢幕貼很近
何必咧?
剛剛我們不是看到很多運動員嗎?
他們希望自己在場上是很急躁還是很冷靜的
當然是很冷靜的
那在交易的市場跟在棒球場上跟在籃球場上都一樣
你需要那个超然
用旁观者的角度看这整个局
你就可以很轻松的做这件事
好吗
脾气来的光一边就够赔的
对光一边就够你赔的
管他什么多空
重点是那个情绪
好不好
来那如何不贪
我这边不是全部的东西
但基本上大方向就是不要管别人
不要看新闻就跟着冲进去
不要看群組 人家衝就衝
我記得我在幾週以前的這種直播
我一直在提醒大家
我說這個
這現在AI股都
長相都很醜 我不喜歡喔
我一直提醒大家
對啊
然後我出去外面聊天
人家問說 欸 股票最近怎麼樣
我說我等他回來再買吧
但是一直漲呢
人家都不理我
結果你看
現在回來滿地都是尖尖的
下面的隔壁的單子可以吃
这不是很好吗
对吧
那我要如何
不要去管这些
因为我很明确的
有我自己的组件
所以外面做什么
不管
甚至我的房贷
我还很多
我这三年的房贷
我还了
1000我看我还掉我还掉1000的吧
对啊
三年了我还掉1000了
我是故意多还
我不打算我不打算一直一直背房贷
但是人家说房贷就是要那么便宜拿来用
不用怎么样咬我我就是有我的主意
我没有说这样子是好还是坏
但这就是我吧
所以我不让外面来影响我
我也不会去问外面的老师说
请问我这样还房贷是不是不对啊
没有不对啊
我就是我啊
我爽就好
你管我
这样子
懂吗
所以
那个
有人说
我傻傻不懂的利用资金利用
对
很多人很在乎资金利用率
然后那个在乎的
就是刚刚旁边的那个网友的那种
那种
什么
七月不到剩一半的那个本金
有没有
我刚刚看到的上面的那些
就是那些人很在乎资金利用率
所以才会把存款加上借来的钱全部给他凹进去
不要这样啦
这样好不好
来如何不拒
恐惧跟贪婪其实是相对的
你下的越大
你越贪
你自然会越怕
对吧
因为你下的不会大到一个程度会影响你生活
影响你睡眠
你隔壁一早起来看到那个坡洞
哇一下子上面下面上面下面这样子
你会很紧张到一顿饭哦
你中间会想要拿手机出来看盘
还会切到那个损利去看的
那代表你下太大了
懂吗
我是很认真的哦
如果你没有办法三天完全不看盘
然后不管三天的走势
如果你无法这样子代表你下太大
三天而已
你三天都离不开吗
这样好不好
所以你要用睡得着觉的小部位
但是我
我就是一开始部位小
我才要借钱
部位小你借来的钱
好了让你翻好了
你是能借多少钱
你是能翻多少倍
你反而一开始
就要专注的是什么
是先从你的本金
先把你的工作跟家庭
甚至家庭的气氛
那些全部都稳定好
存到一个比较多一点点的本金再进来做那个相对起来你的安全感你遵守纪律的模式会好很多所以用睡得着觉的小部位
有明确而且固定的交易的逻辑
第三个把停损的决定权放在自己身上
不要交给老鱼
不要交给外面的老师
不要交给任何的其他人
或是说就摆在那边飘在那里
等市场来决定你要不要停顺
前一段时间券商不是一直在砍那些断头的人吗
对吧
那些就是因为他们把决定权给交出去的
明明有最一开始的小赔的地方他可以走
但是他们不要
这个我也经历过我也凹单过
我不会去怪这些人
但是这个是过程
你要想办法醒过来
好不好
而且哦
如果你有1000万的人
他开杠杆来做
跟只有
只有100万的人开杠杆来做
跟只有10万的人开杠杆来做
谁比较有本
谁比较不怕
假设全部都开杠杆
都开多少
开500万都去借500万
100万的人跑去借500万
应该借不到
可能顶多借200万而已
对不对
我的意思就是说
越有本的人
他其实越有能力跟你扛
你也不要去管网路上谁老师怎么样
或是老鱼的单子怎么样
你又知道我的本怎么样
你又知道那个人的本怎么样
对吧
每个人都在自己的刻度上
所以你唯一要做的就是
回到你的刻度上
也又回来了
所以不要恐惧跟不要贪婪的方式是
你先回到身上
把自己的家
自己的生活先顾好
然后慢慢扩大扩大扩大
修身齐家治国平天下
才有后面的东西嘛
好不好
杠杆还有波动的耗损
对啊
涨回去原位
那个开杠杆的两倍的那些ETF
它回不去原位
你知道那些ETF
只是拿你的钱来做期货吗
各位知道吧
两倍三倍的这些
它都是拿你的钱
你以为你是买股票
没有
你买做这个股票的
它拿这个钱去做期货
它才有办法开杠杆
那不然呢
那你说老医师你自己乱讲吗没有你去他们各大ETF的官网上面自己去查他的成分你就會看到他有他的股票本身也會有期貨這樣子
好不好
然後最後我的標頭不是有講嗎
那個什麼穩定獲利
如何穩定獲利
對不對
剛好講到這裡
穩定獲利是騙人的
好不好
我們在市場上面
我也不敢跟你講我穩定獲利
我只能跟你说我赚赚赔赔赔赔赔赔
加起来是赚钱的
这个我可以讲
但是我不敢跟你说
我这个月稳定获益
我已经有一套稳定获利的方法
没有
我只要一讲出来屁股就翘起来
然后市场立刻就修理我
我讲的当天就开始赔钱
只要我一觉得自己很稳
当天就是赔
只要我乖乖的慢慢的
也不用真的战战兢兢
我就是慢慢的
就是好像什么事情都不管的
这样做我的
那我的单子就做的顺顺的
好好的这样
好不好
我认不认小钱赚不到钱的人
给他一笔大钱赚不到钱
没错
我身边就有亲身的实例
就是一个朋友
他继承了一大笔遗产
这样子
总之就是继承了
那他本身在继承之前
是完全没有财务能力的人
甚至他的金钱刻度跟金钱的眼界
是很小的
那突然间一笔大的遗产在他身上
他不知道怎么办你知道吗
所以他甚至很常讲说
钱放在我身上就会花掉
所以他就觉得他应该要把钱
用什么方式去投资什么
结果好时不时给他找到那种诈骗的
钱就给诈骗的就这样
所以他那个遗产
只剩下一些些
绝大多数都变成
变成遗忘在外面
给诈骗集团骗走的钱
对啊
因为他并没有
真的认真的把自己给准备好
所以他的碗就这么大
突然间来了一大堆财富给他
不管是遗产还是什么钱
或是种乐透
他的碗就这样子
他没有准备好
这个容器就是装不下
对吧
所以我其实今天的这支影片
这样子讲也很好其实是在先帮大家把那个心里面的那个韧性给准备好让你有机会例如说开始有金钱进到你的生活里
进到你的这个容器的时候
你是有足够的刻度去承受它的
这样好不好
然后下周这个老鱼交易业会暂停一次
我下个礼拜出去外面玩
OK
那我就不跟大家讲去哪里玩
等回来再说了
好不好
就是反正就下个礼拜出去玩暂停一次
那会员频道的同学你们不用担心
我有准备了好几支
是我在那个以前群组里面
我筛选出来一些很经典的影片
然后同学都说很不错的
我会丢上去
同一时间我人在日本的时候
我会晚上我会开那个
那个晚上的那个行情
录一下看一下当时的美盘啊等等的
跟大家聊一下
大概就是这样
所以不用担心
但是这个礼拜二的交易页就没有了
我的书有新的进度
现在的进度就是在跟书商
有很多地方
比如说我要编图一图二
二之一二之二图多少
然后这样子顺过了
我现在正在做这个动作
因为我刚开始交稿给他们
我就是只有图上去而已
我没有编图的顺序
所以现在正在做这个事情
好啦去日本玩
但是我没有说去日本的哪里
这样还好啦
日本那么大
对不对
最好是你会在日本
也抓到我
小娜是不是
有点空方突出现
我看一下
小娜
你确定
你要讲的是现在吗
现在没有
没有
如果这个位置要有空方图
它必须要往下走
再往上这里
然后长出尖尖的上影线
如果你是在这一瞬间跟我讲说
有空方图出现
如果是这个时候
我才会说是好的
好不好
不会
现在这边是两条线的上缘跟下缘
的下缘
小时吗
小10k的空方圖,重點不是圖,來同學們,重點是出現圖的編輯
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕